Due Jesus may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of my
existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary and in
the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do
everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires and may you my beloved
divine will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy
will so intimately that I may never swear from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure
and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will that you never perceive even a
breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels and
saints especially my sweet mother Mary to touch my forehead to imprint on it the holy spirit and
infuse in me true light so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. So we want to begin with August the first 1926 and the title here is that we're
talking about the secret of Jesus. This is a very very important message. We have some very precious
messages tonight. I was longing for my sweet go to Louisa said the life of my life and since he was
not coming I talked to myself how hard is his privation. Jesus doesn't love me anymore she keeps
this up you know and not only have the caresses and the kisses and his great shows of love which he
so abundantly gave me before have they all ended. In other words God is no longer love but his
lovable and in rapturing presence also keeps me waiting longer and longer. Now her problem is very
simple and that is that to use a very Irish expression she spoiled rotten she has seen the Lord so much
she has received so many signs of love and affection from him that she can't tolerate at all that he
isn't continuing and she says that for God what pain she said what a continuous martyrdom and she
describes this martyrdom as a life without life a life without air a life without breath so she's
actually feeling suffocated so when she says Jesus is my life she actually means it literally that she
can only live if he sustains her because her life isn't normal at all. My Jesus have pity on me on
your poor exiled one she says but when I was thinking of this and other things beloved Jesus came out
from within my interior which of course kingdom of God is within and leaning his arms on my
breast he said to me I don't know if that's leaning his elbows on her breast he said
might offer you deceive yourself in saying that I no longer love you as before on the contrary
you must know that my kisses and caresses the shows of love I gave you were the outpouring of my love
unable to contain it in my interior you see for most of us he doesn't actually give you these
external signs he contains it within his own interior how he feels about you and he said I
showed it to you with many loving signs and since between you and me there wasn't a great deal of
work to do I think that's absolutely brilliant wouldn't you love that he could say that about
you as well I would give anything I'd pay him to say that about me that there was very little work
for him to do he said so therefore I showed you the strategies of love everything's for a purpose
he didn't just show her signs just for the sake of it or to give into her or to give into himself
it's not that at all everything is for a purpose and he's telling her that she's actually ready
for heaven I that's incredible there wasn't much to do because we have seen him and read that he
has said before that he was simply dusting her soul well I would think that if my house only needs
a dusting it's not in a bad shape so he didn't have much work to do but this served to prepare you
for the great work that was to be carried out between you and me in other words everything
has a purpose the Lord doesn't waste his time his energy his grace or anything and when one works
he says there's no time to amuse yourself so he says that you have to give up the enjoyment
if you're going to dedicate yourself to a work that needs to be accomplished however in spite of
this love doesn't cease but it has increased a hundred times strengthened and sealed look at
the sealed it's permanent okay so again she's inclined to make decisions that he's not with her
and everything because of her feelings and he's telling her facts are actually different
so in the next paragraph we have a very important piece about the secret of the divine will
now my daughter having shown to you the outpouring of my constrained love it's kept within himself
because the rest of us don't give him the outlet for it okay and he said I wanted to move on to give
you what was contained within me which of course is the divine will that he wanted the whole world
to have I wanted to communicate to you the great secret of the kingdom of my will which had not
been known for the two thousand years of Christianity people only knew about doing God's will so and
I wanted to give you the goods that it contains and when important secrets are communicated
and this is the most important secret of the whole history of creation
that needs to be looked at this is the most important one he's already told us many times
that creation and redemption are leading towards this this is the the culmination of what he wants
to do so he said in that context amusements and kisses and caresses are put aside more so since
the work of the kingdom of the supreme volition is exuberant full of bigger and full of life
and the greatest that can exist in the whole history of the world so there's so much energy
in this he has got to put that energy into louisa and channel it from her out into the world
but something else had to happen which is going to come up in a moment which I find absolutely
fascinating okay therefore manifesting my secret to you surpasses all loves together the fact that
you have been chosen to have this culmination of God's will for the whole human race reveals to you
this is it is the most extraordinary sign of god's love it surpasses all loves together because
in the secret there is the sharing of one's life and of one's good in the secret there is
trust watch this now it's coming up and there is reliance and do you think it's trivial that
your Jesus has trust in you that's incredible and that you are the object of my hope he says
now if you've studied the Bible some of you have studied much more of it than others
with me you will know that the big problem God has all the time no matter where you go from
Genesis to Revelation the problem God has is that we can trust him but he can't trust us
and when you come to the culmination of the Bible in the book of Revelation he can trust
the human race so little that he gets the angels to do his will he can't trust anybody on the earth
so for God to tell a human being that I can trust you and that you're the object of my hope
I mean it's there's no words to explain the privilege the honor the glory the massive grace
that is involved but not just any trust he said or any hope rather the trust of entrusting to you
the kingdom of my will he has handed it over to a little creature who was born the same as the rest
of us and handing over to you the hope that you would place the rights of the kingdom of the divine
will in safety and that you would make it known for me now the thing I find completely fascinating
apart from all the gift and all the privilege and all the rest of it he has louise in a bed
for 64 years and he's going to accomplish this from somebody who can't move out of the house
many of us aren't trying to think that I can do nothing for God because I don't have the opportunity
to go here go there do this do that he says you can do it just right where you are
right where you are you know the most perfect spies are the ones who pretend they're not
and they just carry on as normal and nobody realizes who they are and therefore they could
do their work perfectly and he's saying I have put you in this hidden way in the world and I can
accomplish everything I want in you it doesn't matter what whether you're married or single or
what widowed or whatever your condition is it actually doesn't matter it doesn't matter whether
you're old or young it just simply matters that you will put up to the divine will and
allow the divine will to work in you and through you it's an incredible privilege it's what he's
doing in us and through us what we're doing is opening up and cooperating that's what we're doing
and the more we open up and the more we cooperate and the more we lay down our crown
at his feet as the 24 elders do in the book of Revelation in chapter five anything the Lord
wants they take the crown off their heads and they lay it at his feet that is total surrender
whatever you want and I love that expression of Saint Therese of Lesus where she used to say to
the Lord I choose what you choose from a massive level of surrender but also liberation from the
self so Jesus is trusting her and he will make the divine will known she does ask him every now and
then how on earth are you going to do this I'm stuck in a bed but we're going to have a message
tonight where he lets it out what he's going to do and she has a crisis about it now he said
having entrusted to you the secret of my will my will being the essential part of the divine life
if you have your own book with you would you please put a huge VIP on that it is the essential part
of the divine life I would not know how to give you a greater gift than this so the very fact that
little nobodies like us are allowed to cooperate with the Lord and join in the divine mission at
all it's privileged beyond our capacity to understand how then he said can you say that I love you
less than before when he's explaining this incredible privilege rather you must say that this is the
great work required of you and of me two of us together now we've had loads of examples
in volume 19 alone let alone any other volume where he compares the massive grace that was
given to our blessed mother so that she could be the one through whom redemption came to the world
and this massive grace is given to louisa so that she's the one who can bring the divine will
to the world but considering that the divine will is the essential part of the divine life
to take an ordinary small little creature and to do it through her it's a massive revelation about
god about his humility he could so easily lord it over us he could so easily dominate us he could
so easily force us to do it but no he goes to the tiniest little creature who will cooperate with
him and any other little creature who wants to cooperate with him he'll work through them
the two quarantines twelve nine my power works best in weakness jesus says i think it's two quarantines
twelve nine so he said this is the great work required of you and of me in the kingdom of my will
you must know that i am always now look at the word always always occupied and all intent on working
in you why is that because everything depends on her opening the door and making the way for
the rest of us to go through so at one stage i expand your capacity and then i instruct you and
many times i move on to work actually together with you and other times i actually make up for
you i think that's brilliant will you underline that little bit that at a moment when you can't do
something that he will make up for us he is so intent on his divine will being manifested upon
the earth it's fantastic i make up for you in some he says i'm always occupied and this says that i
love you more and more but with stronger and more substantial love so when i was sitting with that
today they always spent a couple of hours with it just before the class the thing that struck me was
that louis was saying to the lord something like lord do you love me more than these others
just as jesus had said to peter simon some of john do you love me more than these others do
it's really incredible and so jesus responds with facts and not with feelings we're inclined to get
confused on the feelings thing so if you're not feeling very wonderful today you think that the
relationship between you and the lord might have changed it hasn't changed now on august the fourth
1926 he talks about the four floors of the divine will so please do not confuse this with two messages
back in which he spoke about the four different stages of reaching the high height of the divine
will we're going to have a geographical message this time the last one was about our particular
relationship with god so louis has said my days my hours are always a nightmare
in this the very hard privations of my sweet jesus oh how painful it is to pass from light to
darkness absolutely we know that in the physical thing we also know it if we move from a time of
great grace and privilege to a time of trial it's actually very difficult to go from one to the
other but louis is having this constantly this extraordinary presence and then she goes back
into this awful nothingness and while one thinks she's going to enjoy the light he escapes like a
flash she's been saying that since volume one one remains in the dark but even more so become much
more painfully aware of the darkness when you have known the light now when i was under the press
that is the heavy weight of this trial of the privation of the light of my sweet jesus and feeling
that i could take no more my dear life my highest good moved in my interior i want you to notice
how often louis says the same thing that jesus waits until she can take no more i call that his
cliffhanger move he always waits and waits and waits to see would you trust him that extra inch
would you go that extra mile in trusting him and very often the mistake that we make is that
we will give up far too easily and so on the cliffhanger moment he comes he does it all the time
and therefore it's definitely one of his strategies for operating with us
so i said to him jesus how can you leave me now he's just told her he never leaves her but
he has told her that umptain times without you i don't know where i am and he all goodness told me
my daughter what you don't know where you are are you not in my will this is all teachings we've had
for the last ten volumes the house of my will is large and if you're not on one floor you must be
on another one but you're in the house what he's clarifying there is that if you are in the divine
will you're in the divine will whether you have a headache or not and you're in the divine will
whether you're asleep or awake whether you're working or praying it's there all the time it's 24 7 365
you're in my will so if you're not on one floor you run another in fact he said my will has four
floors he loves confusing us you know so do not confuse this with the message we had the last day
it is very different the first floor he said is the low level of the earth this is geography we're
talking about okay it's the low level of the earth that is where you find the sea and the earth and
the plants and the flowers and the mountains and everything else that exists in the lower part of
the universe the low world my will dominates and rules everywhere because his divine will is in
everything it's places that of queen now the thing i cannot explain to you maybe someone else in the
divine will has more experienced in me why it is queen and not king maybe it becomes king when he
has conquered and we have entered the new Jerusalem i don't know but it just strikes me that he says
it's queen it's not king otherwise he's reaching out to louisa because she's a woman i don't know
i just don't can't answer that one it's places always that of queen and it holds everything in the
palm of its hand now the second floor this is geography is that of the sun and the stars and the spheres
so we're going up into the planet and the third one is what he calls the asia sky i think we would
call that the emptiness of space looks blue from where we're standing and the fourth one is the father
land which is mine and that of the saints is the final home so he's going to be telling her that
when you do the rounds you've got to travel on all four floors so it's a totally different message
to the one about the four stages of entering into the divine will so if you go around in the
lower part of the universe these are in your rounds in your act you will find the divine will waiting
for you in the sea that you may unite with it to do what it does as it carries out its love its glory
and its power the divine will waits for you on the mountains also waits for you down in the valleys
and in the flowery fields the divine will waits for you in all things that you may keep at company
so that you may omit nothing even more you will be the repeater of the acts of the divine will and
once you have gone through the first floor move on to the second and then you will find the divine
will waiting for you with majesty in the sun so that its light and its heat may transform you
and make you lose your being and you may know how to love and glorify as a divine will knows how
to love and glorify now there's the point that's being made you're doing your rounds and you go from
the earth and you go into the planets and you go from there into the emptiness of space and you go
up into heaven okay well what is getting out there is that you will learn how to love god and glorify
god as he himself knows how to love and glorify therefore you'll know how to do it in a divine way
okay therefore go around within our house which of course is the entire universe in the works of
your creator because he waits for you everywhere a sam 139 that you may learn his ways oh my goodness
the sams all over the sams lord teach me your ways lord teach me your ways and the tragedy you find
in the book of numbers for example is that the people refuse to learn his ways and that's lamented
in sam 95 so lord teach me your ways i'll give you two examples sam 86 verse 11 and sam 25 verse 4
so it is extremely important for us to learn the lord's ways that is how he acts with us
how he operates with his creatures how he operates in the universe because if we don't learn that
we're just simply saying words we're saying somebody else's words we're simply repeating
somebody else's words but we're not actually going there louisa actually went there and when
you're in the spirit i knew this long before we got to divine will that in the spirit in your prayer
you can travel anywhere you can visit all the people in prison you can visit all the people
who are sick you can visit all the people who are having tragedy you can visit them all in the spirit
there's absolutely total freedom in the spirit so we have to learn his ways and what he wants to do
and the more you learn how he operates in the spirit the more he will use you but if you don't
learn it you'll only be repeating other people's words and they may be nice words but you're only
repeating other people's words you have to learn his ways and you have to repeat what my will does
in all created things that was what louisa was learning in this way you will be sure of being
always in the supreme volition and not only this but you will be always with me and that's what
she's lamenting that she appears to not be with him that he seems to have moved away from her
in the privations which of course is absolutely impossible he can't move away from her they are
inseparable and he's going to say that to her now you must know that i am inseparable from my will
and louisa is inseparable from him because she is completely in the divine will now and i'm inseparable
from my works because if he's not in the mountains and the hills and everything else and in the stars
and in the planets and in the animals and the plants and everything they won't exist i am inseparable
from my will and from my works and therefore since you are in the divine will i will be with you
and you will be with me but in a more superior way than just simply seeing him in the flesh and i want
to give you two Corinthians 5 16 where the early Christians complained that there were sort of
second-class citizens because after all the apostles and the first crowd had actually seen
Jesus and Saint Paul says that that's not how you see even if you saw him in the flesh and you knew
him in the flesh that's not the way it is now we all know him in the spirit and in the divine will
we all know him in the divine will and we all know him as the divine will operating in us no matter
what your previous experience was so that's two Corinthians 5 16 so having said this he disappeared
like a flesh and i remained in the dark that's just the comparison between the darkness and the light
much more than before but continuing my acts in the supreme volition so she knows that she is to
continue the work that she's called to do but while i was doing this i prayed him to come back to his
little daughter and this time i love this i absolutely love this she knows exactly how to get around him
i think that when a woman is married long enough she knows exactly how to get around her husband
otherwise what is she doing all these years watch what louisa's going to do now this is so
feminine i i had to laugh i prayed him to come back to his little daughter saying to him watch
this now how to pray my Jesus i pray you by the power of your own will and since your will is spread
throughout the whole of creation filling it completely it is your own will that praise you in the song
to come back to your little newborn it prays you in each star it prays you in the azure sky
to hasten to come to the one who cannot live without you it supplicates you in the sea and in the roaring
waves in its sweet murmuring to come quickly to your little exiled one don't you hear my love my
voice in your will resounding in all creation things and in all creation praying supplicating
sighing crying for you to return to the little one of your will how can so many voices not move
you to pity how can so many sighs not push you and not make you fly that means fly back to me
don't you know oh jesus that it is your will that prays you and if you do not listen to your will
it is your will that pays the price my she knows exactly how to get around him
and i believe you cannot do without listening to your own divine will so while i was saying this
and much more i i think that i would have thought what i've just read is enough no no she said there
was much more my sweet jesus moved in my interior because he hasn't gone anywhere he is within her
and we have been reading that since the very earliest volumes that the kingdom of god is within you
that is luke 1721 and one karinthians 3 16 no you not that you are the temple of the living god
and the spirit of god dwells in you he always comes to her out of her own interior
so he hasn't gone anywhere and sharing his bitterness with me which were too many so here she is
pleading with him to come back she wants the the beauty of the the love side of their relationship
and he shows her the only thing he has at that moment which is the bitterness that's coming from
the earth through its rebellion and sin and she said how many sad things that he showed and how
pierced his heart was so while she is longing for him she has to realize that he's not just dealing
with his little exiled one that he is dealing with all of the exiled ones he's dealing with his
whole church and he has to deal with all centuries as well so afterwards as though wanting to cheer
himself making himself seen with his usual pen of light i like the word usual that means this has
happened many many times but she doesn't mention it very often she has mentioned it a few times
but not very often with his pen of light of course he's in the spirit okay and if he's going to write
he's going to let her see a picture of him writing but of course he doesn't need paper or parchment
or anything else what he does is he writes on our spirit and that's Jeremiah 30 to 34 that i will
write my law on your heart it's an interior writing so he has his usual pen of light in his hand
and he told me my daughter let's put everything aside let us speak about the kingdom of my supreme
will which interests me much so to cheer himself from all the bitterness that was coming from the
earth he turns to speak about his divine will because that's where the earth is going to recover
and come back absolutely into God's order and God will be able to have his will done on earth
as it is in heaven so it cheers him to speak about it and therefore i would give you Jeremiah 29 11
i know the plans i have in mind for you plans for peace and not disaster reserving a future full of
hope for you and Jesus has said that to her many times as we go through the volumes let us prepare
a future full of hope even though at this moment they're in a disaster so Jesus said to her don't you
see how i'm always in the act of writing the qualities of the divine will the celestial laws of
the divine will the power of the divine will its divine prejudice its enchanting beauty its infinite
joys the order and the perfect harmony that reigns in this kingdom of the divine faith i'm always
writing this in the depths of your soul now i don't know your reaction to this at this particular
moment but my reaction is lord please take up that pen and write all of that in my soul as well
and in the soul of everyone who is trying to live in your divine will let each one of us experience
you writing all of this wonder in our souls so that we can in fact do what you want us to do
and respond in the way that you want us to respond first he said i make the preparations
i form in you all the properties of the kingdom of the divine will and then i speak to you
so that by feeling is what is written in the book i would say experiencing experiencing its
properties within yourself you may be the spokesperson or i would say the postman of my will you will
be the crier of it you will be its telegraph he uses all the things that people have discovered
and he's going to talk about electricity in a minute so the telegraph the postman the town
crier whatever image you have of someone proclaiming a message he said you're going to be that for me
but notice she has to experience it in herself she notices that he is writing he says he's doing it
entirely within her own being and once she has experienced it she will be able to give it to others
now it would be extremely difficult for us to give divine will treasures to another person
if we hadn't experienced anything of it it would only just be empty words you can only give what you
have you can't give what you don't have so the one who proclaims this with the greatest effect
and the greatest grace is of course the one who has experienced it at that level
so he said you will be a little trumpet with this a shrill sound now the trumpet with the shrill sound
is the ram's horn the shofar it gives a very primal shrill sound and you may call attention
to those passing by to listen to you notice passing by that's a very interesting expression
because when you study the scriptures the lord is always passing by and the expression passing by
in the scriptures means that in the events of your life and the things that happen whether they're
good bad or indifferent the lord is always passing by it's always an opportunity for grace it's always
an opportunity to grow and the mistake we can make is to let an opportunity pass in other words we
let the lord pass by we don't say what the two disciples said on the road to a mayos oh no come in
stop with us and then he revealed himself to them in a new way so we have to be the people who the
lord can use to spread the wonder of the kingdom of the divine will to others the teachings i give
you about the kingdom of my will will be like many electric wires now you've heard me say before
that whatever has just been discovered on the earth the lord uses that and so people have become
aware of the discovery of electricity but that you can't have it unless your house is wired up for it
and it's going to use that to tell us that we have to be wired into the grid of the divine will if we
want the divine will to operate in us as well if we want the massive light of the unity of the light
of the divine will to be shining in us and through us we have to be connected to the grid that makes
sense doesn't it wouldn't be silly if my house was all wired up and i wasn't connected to the grid
so it'll be like many electric wires which are such that when the appropriate communications
are established that means you've made all the connections to the grid and the necessary preparations
are made a single wire is enough to give light to entire cities and provinces once the preparation
has been done and everything has been set up then you can switch on the light i remember a very
wonderful moment in my life when we turned on electric light for the first time on top of a high
mountain in the camaroon in west africa and the people had never had electricity before it was
totally astonishing and the reaction of the people was totally astonishing as well but there was a
awful lot of preparation to that and one of the preparations was that we had to have a whole team
of men drag a huge container of a very high mountain they had to do it in stages because we
wouldn't have the electricity without this gadget so once you've set it up then you can have the light
and i remember that particular night we waited until midnight and we got the chief to flick the
switch and we talked about god is light and in him there is no darkness and they were really able
to hear it so the power of the electricity with rapidity greater than that of wind gives light to
public and private spaces so here once you are connected to the grid of the divine will it can
happen instantly the lord can do the most wonderful things the power of the electricity will be the
fiat itself which with enchanting rapidity will form the light that will cast away the night of
the human will and the darkness of the passions it's wonderful the way he's able to use all kinds
of images to get the message across oh how beautiful the light of my will will be in seeing it people
will dispose the devices in their souls in order to connect the wires of the teachings
look at the way he's using electricity it's absolutely brilliant
okay once the teaching of the divine will is given to anybody the people listening can connect the
wires of their souls to the teachings and enjoy and receive the power of the light that the
electricity of the supreme will contains that means that as i am actually speaking trying to
reflect on this in some way that the lord can accomplish this in you in much shorter time
than you will blink it could just be instantaneous but we've got to open up we've got to in this case
switch on the light or make the connections okay do you want to see what will happen he said look
i take one wire of my teachings linked to your soul and you omit your voice within the wire
say something he says say you know i love you or i don't i bless you or something whatever you want
say said then keep looking so now he's doing an experiment with her and so louisa said i love you
and that i love you changed into characters of light that he's trying to illustrate something
spiritual for us so in the divine will she says i love you those words were changed into characters
of light and the electric power of the supreme volition multiplied it in such a way that that i
love you of light would go through the whole vault of the heavens fix itself in the sun in each star
penetrate into heaven fix itself on each one of the blessed in heaven form its crown of light at the
foot of the divine throne and enter even into the bosom of the supreme majesty in some wherever the
divine will was there it would form its electric light so a person in the divine will emitting this
prayer the lord takes it and does this absolutely incredible thing with it so whenever the divine
will was there it would form the electric light and jesus continued my daughter have you seen what
power the electricity of the supreme fia has and how it reaches everywhere the electricity of the
earth diffuses down below at the most it doesn't have the power to reach even the stars but the power
of my electricity diffuses down below op-hi in the hearth absolutely everywhere and when the wires
are disposed that's the souls with enchanting rapidity it will make its way into the midst of
creatures once the acts are done in the divine will the lord then will see to it that they will
reach absolutely everywhere it's the most beautiful image that's given to us but he tells us that he's
using this image of electricity to speak of our acts that have got to be transformed into light
because god is light and only light can enter into that divine light and our acts have got to be
transformed into love because god is love and nothing on holy or unworthy can enter that presence
as we've said many times in hebrews 1214 and also in revelation 21 and 22 nothing can enter that
holy city that's outside of the divine will and therefore the continuous transformation has got
to take place in us so let's look at August the 8th 1926 our work is to cooperate with god
he's working in us all the time but our work is to cooperate with him so as i was in my usual
state i felt all abandoned in the arms of jesus louisa said and he moving in my interior said my daughter
the more the soul is identified with me that would be level three going into level four the more the
soul is identified with me and going deeper and deeper and deeper into level four the more i can
give her and the more she can take at the very early stages of this journey people have so much
put in front of them they may not actually be able to take much but as we go deeper and deeper yes
we can take more and we can give more it happens he said and he gives an example of a little stream
near an ocean but there's a wall in between the stream and the ocean so it's like the sea and a
little stream which are separated by a sea wall so much so that if the wall were removed the sea
and the little stream would become one single area now if the sea overflows because the little river
is near it the little stream receives the water from the sea if it's roaring waves rise in lowering
again they unload themselves under the little stream that's because the little stream is beside
the sea it can get disadvantage the water of the sea pours into it through the cracks in the wall
as well so the tiny little stream constantly receives the waters of the sea and because it is little
it keeps swelling up and it gives back to the sea the water it has received it can't keep it
and then it receives it again so you have this very alive movement going between the two
giving and receiving giving and receiving giving and receiving but if the little stream
were far away the sea wouldn't be able to give and the little stream wouldn't be able to receive
its distance would put it in the condition of not even knowing that the sea was there
it's an absolutely beautiful beautiful image the sea is god and the little stream is us and we have
to be as close as we can in union with god and in the divine will to get more and more benefit from
the sea of the divine will but the further we are away from it the harder it is to actually benefit
so the wall is our humanity in the next paragraph so while seeing this he showed to my mind in practice
the act of the sea and the little stream so he shows it to her so that she can see it it's not just a
intellectual information my daughter he said the sea is god and the little stream is the soul
the wall that separates them is the human nature which makes one distinguished god and the creature
the overflowing the waves which rise continuously to unload themselves into the little stream
are my divine will that wants to give so much to the creature that the little stream being filled
and swelling up will overflow that's john seven thirty seven to thirty nine fountains of living
water will spring up from you for other people so the little stream may form its waves swollen by
the wind of the supreme will and may pour back into the divine sea to be filled again in such a way
as to be able to say I live the life of the sea as Galatians 220 I no longer live Christ lives
in me I live the life of the sea that's of saying I live the life of the divine will I'm in the divine
will and even though I'm little I too do what it does I overflow I form my waves I rise and I try
to give to the sea what it gives to me that's exactly what we've been talking about for so long
about our acts and receiving from the Lord and giving back to him we have this continuous divine
commerce going on you know that our countries would absolutely collapse economically if people
were not giving and receiving to each other buying and selling there must be this continuous flow
all the time and for our souls to reach a fullness as well there must be this giving and receiving
between us and the Lord so the soul who is identified with me now that's actually living in the divine
will 24 7 3 6 5 and let's yourself be dominated by my will now domination is that she has surrendered
her human will she allows herself to be dominated by my will that soul is the repeater of the divine
acts her love her alterations her prayers and everything else that she does is the outpouring of
God this is fantastic it's the outpouring of God which she receives so as to be able to say
it is your love that loves you in me and through me it's your alterations that adore you through me
and in me it's your prayers that pray you and that's exactly what Louisa had been doing there
a page back when she was asking him to come back it's your will that investing me makes me do what
you do and to give back to you your very own things so there you've got the response that the Lord
has been looking for all these centuries not only of the christian centuries but the centuries
of the mosaic covenant as well for the human race to reach back that love is requited it isn't
left completely alone so then Louisa said Jesus kept silent and then is so taken by an irresistible
emphasis of love i think that's an absolutely utterly awkward statement in other words just
reaching out in love spontaneous love okay it's the translator hasn't got a good handle on the
english he added all the power of my will how great you are you alone can unite the greatest
and the highest being with the littlest and the lowest being making them one i call that the i
am not finds itself in the great i am john three thirty he must increase and i must decrease but
i find i am not the prophet i am not the messiah i am not this i'm not that i'm not anything
but i find my completion completely in him that's absolutely fantastic
jesus says the divine will alone unites the greatest and the highest being which is god
with the littlest and the lowest being which is us making them one you alone have the power of
emptying the creature of all that does not belong to you and that is a major part of the journey
the self emptying major part of the journey because if we don't do the self emptying he can't fill us
to be able to form in her with your reflections the eternal sun which filling heaven and earth
with its rays goes to blend with the sun of the supreme majesty i mean what he offers to the nothing
is totally absolutely amazing saint paul says in one karinti in six seventeen that we become one
spirit with him so that was understood at the very earliest stages of the church so we shouldn't be
so amazed at what the lord says here also john 14 20 you and me and i in you both completely one
and this is what we're talking about here so he says you alone have the power of communicating
the supreme strength in such a way that with your strength the soul can rise to that single
act of god the creator only god can work this incredible miracle inside of us
and my daughter he said when the soul does not live in the unity of my will she loses the one
strength now this strength is the strength of the divine will that enables us to do everything we
can't do okay so the one strength is like the one will so when we don't live in the divine will
she loses the strengths in all her actions and therefore all her acts not coming out of this same
single strengths remain divided among themselves love is divided the action separated the prayer
is disjointed and divided all the acts of the creatures are poor meager without light and so
patience is poor you've never been there have you
charity is weak obedience is crippled humility is blind prayer is mute sacrifices without life
because since my will is missing the one strength that she needs to be able to do anything is missing
john 15 5 without me you can do nothing Philippians 4 13 with him I can do everything but without him
I can do nothing and notice that he's emphasizing that the divine will gives supernatural strength
to us I think traditionally we would call that fortitude and the way I describe fortitude is
the steel girders that they put into skyscrapers so they can survive a hurricane
that strength that enables our patience to be rich and our charity to be great and our obedience
to be spontaneous and our humility to be wide open and our prayer to be full of love and praise
and all the rest of it and so that your spiritual life is vibrant exuberant full of life that's
the strength of the divine will it's just I prefer the word fortitude because it means more to me
so we can do it with this strength or with this fortitude we can't without it therefore the people
who are not in the divine will are left not only divided among themselves but adulterated by the
human will and so each one is left with its own defect so to summarize that paragraph
the divine will is strength the human will is weakness you can do nothing with the human will
you can do everything with the divine will okay then he gives us an example in the next paragraph
and he says this is what happened to Adam by withdrawing from the supreme will he lost that
great strength that great fortitude of his creator and since he was left with his own limited human
strength he felt hardship in all that he had to do more so since the strength that he employed in
performing one action would debilitate him in having to do another he would not feel the same strength
so in other words he had a certain amount of strength and the more he would try to use it he
had less and less and less when you're in the divine will you have more and more and more because
the divine is infinite and it's a very good illustration of john 15 5
so he would feel debilitated so he touched the poverty of his actions now this is a spiritual
poverty that is not positive it's negative he touched it with his own hand this expression that
louisie uses to touch with your own hand you have bitter experience not having the same strength
they were not only divided but each one had its own defect it's the same as a rich lord who possesses
most extensive properties as long as they belong to one owner alone only he can show off he can
make big purchases who knows how many servants he maintains under himself and with the large proceeds
that he receives he keeps on making new purchases but suppose that this property were to be divided
among his heirs well that's it the great power is lost the moment it's divided it's lost he can
no longer show off as before or make new purchases he must limit himself in his expenditures and
his servants are few so his greatness his lordship has vanished what is left is just barely the traces
of it and that is what happened to adam by withdrawing from my will he lost the one single strength of
his creator and with that he lost his lordship his dominion and he did not feel the ability to show
off in good anymore the same happens to one who is not completely abandoned in the arms of my will
i want you to know it was not completely it's the not completely thing human beings have the ability
to if they're seventy percent committed that they think well that's enough you know
it's the same happens to for one who is not completely abandoned in the arms of my will
because with the divine will the strength of good converts into one's nature in the divine will
to be good and to do what god wants you to do becomes part of your own nature
and that poverty that awful spiritual inability to do anything no longer exists
so i want to leave it there for tonight i think there's plenty there for us to look at
and the final challenge there that we would surrender completely and to surrender completely
is uteronomy six four to ten hero israel the lord your god is one lord and you shall love
the lord your god with all your heart all your soul all your mind and all of your being the lord
wants everything because when we give him everything then we can receive everything from him so thank
you for listening